Emily: I wanted to get a head start on figuring
out my career and really having an idea of
if this is the world for me, if I really want
to be in DC. Having this opportunity to both
work but still get my politics courses in
was perfect.
My favorite part of the internship would probably
be feeling like I'm finally in the middle
of something that really not just matters,
because what happens at Hillsdale obviously
matters too--getting an education--but being
out in the world and being able to influence,
even if it's tiny little ways, legislation
and what's going on specifically on Capitol
Hill.
It can prepare you to really be able to see
other people's viewpoints. When you're in
a city that can have so many controversies
over everything, being able to understand
where they're coming from but still hold fast
to your beliefs is something that Hillsdale
really prepares you for. WHIP itself is a
great way to test that out.